people keep saying oh you know Civil War
is a stupid thing to say and it's like
dude it's not just that Trump has been
indicted on like' 91 or 94 counts it's
not just that they've arrested his
lawyers it's not just that a couple of
his lawyers have just been sentenced to
five and six years of probation for
being his lawyers it's not just that
they're going after Alex Jones in what
is clearly going to destroy a media
outet uh and that he got no trial for it
it's not just that Donald Trump was
found in a summary judgment to have
committed fraud without a trial in New
York it's not just that a judge said
Donald Trump's properties are worth a
fraction of what they're actually worth
even to the protest of uh of Finance
experts and real estate experts it is
not just that they have been targeting
Trump supporters J Sixers solitary
confinement it's not just that far
leftists have received no penalty for
The Hundreds who stormed the capital
recently they light light slap on the
wrist it's not just